hello everybody my name is markiplier
and apparently I'm trapped in Rick's
game haha so anyway that music is
disturbing in this game is made by the
same guy that made slender space so this
should prove to be interesting to say
the least
okie dokie created by rick murray the
creator of slender space
as i stated before based on me based all
about i'm so honored that people make
games about me and this is like this is
ridiculous
i'm so i'm so happy that people do this
it's crazy thank you so much for making
a game about me well unless i made fun
of mercilessly in this game in which
case no thank you
hey look it's my haha i just put on my
moustache excuse me these look like
these are the dead space type boxes and
they're what are you what did I just get
was that a flashlight of some sort I
don't know what I just got high is them
gonna jump out at me he J he okay I'm
feeling that this one might be locked
well out loud where was that loud dark I
can't see anything okay I forgot what I
was saying people have noticed recently
that I start sentences and don't finish
them it's not that I don't want to
finish it's that I literally literally
get what I was saying you know it's kind
of weird I oh oh my oh my goodness oh my
goodness ha ha somewhat painted blood
mustaches on all of my pictures that's a
little weird okay so can I get that
there we go mustache - ha ha I am
thoroughly freaked out right now I've
got a psycho crazy person after me
alright
I'm trapped in this ship hi he's young
yeah jump out of me well this is
definitely creepier than the other game
that was made about me not enough that
makes it better
ha ha ha yes
switch it all sudden switches 0 for came
up what does that mean
why is that it oh so what do you like
about my channel Rick well why why I
have no idea okay
I'm in some sort of maze huh okay nope
ha ha ha
that was right in my ear ha ha ha and I
saw that I saw that mannequin thing
alright let me just pick up my good old
Mustang uh I'm not sure what dr.
markiplier is doing he's going on about
markers and stuff about him being - bro
I think he's losing his mind I'm
starting to wonder if he's still fit for
duty nurse yamimash
now I go back out dad right yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'll go around you
I'll play your little game you rogue ha
ha ha ha ha this game isn't fun anymore
I sure I still haven't seen a switch is
there a switch over there by that sign I
don't know
how am I supposed to know I'm just a
stupid doctor sure chunk okay can I go
no no thank you
hello huh I've got the volume turned way
up again like everyone should when they
play horror games you got turn that
volume up man
that's what yeah look my girl ah I can't
smash these though can i I can't
damn it hi Lala okay I thought I came
through here before seems like I have
gotten lost
oh look a mustache how inconspicuous I'm
so scared right now it's not funny if
only Wade was here cries oh look no
mannequins this time good good ha ha ha
ha they realized that I am too proud to
be beaten by mannequins you're way too
close to me ha ha ha ha ha all right
Yeah right all right all right
ha ha ha ha oh wait a minute I've been
here before I thought it's hard to tell
where I've been and where I haven't cuz
these panels in the distance they kind
of look the same kind of look the same
look a bit the same okay I can sprint so
let's uh try to hurry through okay
there's that one I can tell where I've
been
because of the mannequin placement I
didn't notice that well we did I I don't
know maybe I did ah-ah-ah-ah-ah how do I
get back to where I was before I I don't
remember okay I think I think I'm on the
right track here wait a minute I think I
think maybe I been down this way before
oh hello wait a minute I was oh this is
the entrance hang on I see a stache over
there I'm gonna just and go really
quickly whoa uh uh I'm Isaac Clark I see
a mustache over there though how do I
get through there I see it I see it in
the distance okay whatever was there a
way through here knew that's a negative
all right I'm not gonna be open uh okay
so which way have I gone stop dropping
cans all over the place it's not
appreciat
oh I been here okay I've been there so
that means that I go aha
this looks different aha I got a switch
oh no this is switch that's a lock
thingy Oh what the hell how about in
here it's like I'm sliding on ice here
no no oh Naha oh nothing
good ah my neck Oh
hi nice ass here good job on jumping out
at me all that really hurt I tightened
up way too much I got a cramp in my
shoulder now okay so I need to find one
more switch where could it be I wonder
oh here it is hello
oh I know something was behind me uh-huh
okay so about that keep in there oh I've
been there okay I been it all I think I
got all the switches now it's just gotta
figure out how to restore power to the
area I don't know I don't want to know
wait a minute am I going the right way I
don't even know I'm going the right way
how do I restore power to the area oh
man haha I don't think I want to know oh
man
well good job guy who made this game
aren't you just a minute wait there's a
red light glowing over here pabu ski
shower babe you what oh man well at
least there are lights that's all I can
really hope for hep fly space pot out of
here what what do you mean fly space
back now haha oh thank you you obviously
knew that I was gonna fall off ergo you
set up safeguards to prevent my
stupidity from overriding my awesome bro
now why am i sliding like I'm on ice god
dammit I'm like a children no I didn't I
wasn't even close that time you
shouldn't make games for me
I'm Way too I didn't even do anything
what the hell I didn't even do anything
oh my god
hahaha I'm not stupid
I'm not stupid okay I got that mustache
and I swear I bet the guy who made this
is watching it like how I get off I
before that time oh my god I'm not a fan
of yo anymore that's my impression of
the I watched the video now god I'm
sliding like about ice it's not my fault
I didn't jump that time okay I'm never
gonna get through this cuz I'm the most
incompetent gamer there ever was and I'm
spending time collecting the all these
mustaches and there was still that
locked container that I don't know what
what's going on over there Oh yuck yuck
Oh yuck yuck I'm so stupid
oh York York okay anyway all right
everyone settle under now I'm in a mess
oh oh oh my name is Mark I'll know
anyway now's a nice segue into my own
demise err so let's not miss these jumps
how about that yeah oh oh that was a
close one I bet you expected no oh good
hahaha I thought I was gonna fall to my
death okay so the space pod is over
there but I'm gonna be an idiot and go
over here
Oh
did I fall off okay
I'm not cool bro I thought okay Hari
whenever there's a counter for how many
times I fall enough okay he'll okay so
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah uh who is keeping
track who's keeping track I'm not doing
it intentionally guys I'm not huh sorry
I'm hacking up a lung here okay this is
awesome I like it that one messed me up
that one got me good
that one got me two good okay
so slide down I'm starting to think is
there anything over don't do it again
don't do it again
you did it again okay there's nothing
over there I thought it wasn't gonna do
it again it did it again haha oh god I'm
really not trying to fall guy haha sorry
I still got that gob and when that scare
happened I inhaled a lot of spit and
didn't go very well
haha alright anyway so enough enough
about my problems
yeah okay let's just get out of here and
hope there's not another one alright
don't don't do it don't do it again I
got a cramp in my I don't want just let
me out
I got all the mustaches
ah
haha alright
hahaha oh let's turn that down a bit
okay hahaha
that might be the best jump scare I've
ever had the first time of course man
that was good I mean when I played
slender space it was a really scary game
and really well done so I'm honored I'm
really honored that this guy made a game
about me that's so cool I gotta turn
that down more sorry I did I inhaled her
gross but I inhaled something so I'm not
gonna die I got a real bad cramp on my
shoulder huh so far this game has been
more damaging to me than helpful
oh my god ah sorry I cut some stuff out
there I was hacking up a lug jaw wife
sincerely I'm cried half from coughing
out from scares but sincerely Rick
Murray thank you so much for making it
you're amazing thank you so much for
making this game about me and having me
in slender space - I'm so glad - your
fan and man what was it that locked
cabinet I want to know did I miss
something there I got all the mustaches
so there you have it anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos and I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
but I move this is only a little bit
hi there that says that's on my
sculpture of wait in case you didn't
know yeah that you can tell I mean
obviously you discover
wait made that during drug minecraft one
of my favorite
my big eyes like part